i think the guys just played like
they're capable of um
you know i did a terrible job of putting
us in some really poor situations early
in that game i made no excuses about it
our guys ended up responding we made
some better adjustments and the guys
made the plays i saw a lot of individual
efforts that were outstanding i saw a
resilient group i saw a team that stayed
connected when you go down 28 to 3
against a really good football team and
they just kept battling they kept
swinging i hate it for our guys that it
ended up the way that it did and came
down to some of the things that it came
down to but uh we're a tough group we're
mentally tough group we're going to use
this as an opportunity to respond
and we're not going to allow the bills
to beat us twice we'll go back we'll
look at the film we'll be able to clean
up some stuff i thought there was a lot
of good stuff as well so
um you know they made some plays we made
a lot of plays and uh you know we
definitely did everything we could to
steal the momentum back and to be able
to come away with the win ultimately it
didn't go in our favor for some things
that sometimes are out of your control
and that's unfortunate but uh we're
going to continue to move forward and i
just can't wait to get back to work with
this group i love what this team's about
i think we can use this as a real
opportunity to gain some some strength
and some momentum
unfortunately these are things that if
they occur early enough in the season
and you're able to respond the right way
they can be great learning ops that
don't cost you in the long run
[Music]
as a team we got to be better we got to
make sure that we're keeping our foot on
the pedal and we got to place that game
away um you know i'm very happy with how
resilient this team was but i'm also a
little little mad at myself for allowing
us to kind of dip right there not um you
know executing like we should have i put
the ball in harm's way too often um but
then today we got a victory that's all i
care about
there is josh allen an mvp candidate at
plus 3 000 odds as of last week i have a
feeling those odds what was i thinking
what we saw yesterday what do you mean
what were you thinking i should have put
some money down on my boy blue you know
easy money
you know just a little change
let's see how it all plays out but so
far so good although yesterday they got
a little nervous 28 to 3 the most
dangerous lead in football apparently as
the falcons would seriously right bills
blew that 28-3 lead and you have to give
the bills credit for finding a way wow
come back and make it happen with an
epic drive that ultimately was fueled by
a highly questionable pass interference
penalty gabriel davis a very bright spot
rookie receiver for the bills he got hit
in the end zone
not really and josh allen said after the
game would talk to him on the phone he
said
you know i'm not the type of guy that
likes to win a game that way but i'm not
going to complain about it so he knows
he knows they know they know they got a
gift there and and there are bad calls
throughout the course of a given game
that happens but that was a gift that
was a that was a man unbelievable that
they threw the flag in that spot and
we've seen that this year where the
officials are willing to throw flags for
offensive and defensive pass
interference at a point in the game
where in past years they would just let
them play chris they didn't let them
play there and that helped set up the
win but however you get it you get it
you take it and you run out of the
stadium 3-0 no you're right i mean we
had it makes me the referees that's
where i think like the no fans is that
easier to throw the flag in those
moments right i mean even in hey week
one you know the the rams were a
beneficiary off of a pass interference
call right with gallop and jaylen ramsey
down the sideline that people question
then so football gods usually even
things out either way that was a
very questionable call the one thing i
don't like is like a defensive player is
allowed to stand there and that's his
area you can't just run him over because
like the wide receiver on a piece of
paper supposed to go that way if the
defender's there the receiver has to run
around him he doesn't get to go wait no
my coach said i go this way so i'm
allowed to run him over ref that's where
i don't get it
excuse me either way it was an awesome
game mcveigh's right the rams are going
to have a lot to build on
um josh allen's on fire
the 28-10 interception though that's the
play
allen throws a ball up to dawson knox
right mike and
he catches the ball and they give an
interception to the rams which i believe
was the wrong call all the way there and
that really changed the game because now
it's whoa the rams got the ball they
kind of got the offense rolling they
scored touchdown as three and out bills
rams are rolling they scored touchdown
bills start to drive again sack fumble
aaron donald rams score again they're in
the lead it was unbelievable how quickly
it all turned but that play right there
was the big play where you know you talk
about the referees yeah they screwed the
rams over at the end of the game but
they screwed the bills over on this play
right here i haven't heard one person
say this wasn't a catch i don't know how
you give the interception here but uh
bills get the win nonetheless
yeah it happened twice yesterday we
talked earlier about the bears falcons
game on the nick foles first drive and
it happened in this game as well and on
aaron donald one thing alan said is
first of all he said before the game he
said aaron donald go easy on me today
that's not going to work and alan was
always aware of where aaron donald was
and and we saw that play where donald uh
made the sack ball came out and it came
out and he recovered the fumble right
aaron donald is unstoppable and one
thing alan said we need to have a better
plan for 99 if we see the rams again and
i kind of like that that implicit
confidence
that they're going to be seeing
an nfc team yeah to cap the season
potentially in the super bowl i kind of
like that i i do too but they should
feel confident that way they're in the
conversation for one of the best teams
in the afc i mean we know the chiefs and
ravens are one too but the buffalo bills
are sitting there right in that
conversation for number three and we're
watching an offense with scheme talent
and a quarterback mic that you so often
talk about guys that can make things
happen when nothing's there we're seeing
that all come to a pinnacle and we're
seeing special things every week i mean
third and 22 against the rams scrambling
out to the right throwing a rifle for a
first down all that the one thing i'm
concerned about a little bit is where
the hell is the bill's defense the first
three weeks of the year they've been a
little concerning we thought it was
gonna be the other way around it's
offensive heavy football team right now
but still the bills are one of the best
teams in the afc
week eight week 16 patriots and bills
get together should we have all the
great games another great hour pft live
still to come we'll be back right after
this
la rams buffalo bills the bills the
dreaded 28-3 lead in this game and then
they blow it but they come back they win
it josh allen has a monster game tony
and we've seen this from the bills
almost every week they they come out on
fire they get a lead they relax a little
bit their defense gives up some plays
and then
they push the envelope again with allen
he's playing great football and making
big plays for them
they're going to be tough when they get
a little consistency going i want to
focus on the rams defense to me they
just played entirely too much his own
defense when you're playing a guy 20
plus million dollars a year jalen ramsey
he has to lock up you have to lock him
up as a coach with stefan diggs i mean
he should be locked up on him the entire
game but just too many missed tackles
guys running free in the secondary if on
the rams defensive coach i'm just
keeping it simple so these guys can play
fast and they can be effective but he
threw a bad ball up in the traffic it
shouldn't have been called an
interception but that turned the game
around he took a couple of sacks that he
didn't need to take and got it got the
field position messed up but the one
thing about him he forgets about what
happened and he pushes forward
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports